hello everyone welcome to rational
science directly from rankford Germany
and we've had a a lot of global cooling
over here I haven't seen the sun in over
two months uh today it appeared a little
bit but uh in general I have no idea
what this Global uh warming is over here
it's global cooling in Germany anyways
uh we got a busy day today so I'm gonna
be skipping the typical Extinction
segment I'm going to dive directly into
some of the subject matter of today
because some people ask some questions
make comments and I need to address
those before we can move on okay so
let's get on with it here's uh some of
the issues that were raised okay by
these folks I'm going to start with
their issues the ones that they raised
and we're going to address them today
here it is the first one says The Ether
cannot be anything but a continuous
fluid
otherwise it cannot be any action at a
distance possible
it's a very it's very similar to your
rope idea
absolutely not are your roasts made of
particles too absolutely not you know
and we made that very clear it's made
out of a single thread that's all there
is in the universe in its closed loop
thread that looks more or less like this
like a rubber band that's what it looks
like closed loop thread okay once again
okay so no it's not made of particles uh
the thread is made of atoms right I mean
the rubber band is made of particles
discrete particles the thread is made of
a single piece it's flexible even though
it's made of a single piece okay anyways
we're not getting into that but just so
you know I mostly agree with what you
say about physics well no because
there's a difference between criticizing
physics you know mathematical physics
the nonsense of mathematical physics the
entire uh nonsense that's been around
for the last hundred years uh yeah that
you can criticize that uh the electric
Universe criticizes it the John
Chappelle Society all these people
criticize
the mathematical establishment but a
scientist is not a Critic okay scientist
is the guy who gets in the ring and
fights not the guy who is in the stand
you know down there saying hey why don't
you hit him with the right one with the
left and no no that's a Critic okay uh
it's the one who gets in the ring and
fights and proposes theories the one who
explains how this universe works that's
the scientist not the critic who says
you're wrong or whatever you know even
though you make an analysis of the other
fellow's theory that alone does not
constitute science science is
explanation
uh physical interpretation in the case
of physics
you gotta let go of this e uh idea of
either being only a concept especially
made of particles if the ether was made
of particles then what would be that uh
other stuff in between The Ether
particles empty space yeah it's a
question for you to answer okay you have
to answer that question I'm not the
proponent of ether okay uh but if you're
gonna propose The Ether you have to tell
the crowd
the audience what you mean by Ether okay
the the ball is in your court and you
still don't realize that I guess
uh how would there be uh interaction
possible between two objects in the
universe in the universe if there were
gaps of nothingness between each
particle you got the right questions but
it's up to you to answer them I mean
you're the proponent of ether not me
okay so you are supposed to tell the
crowd what you mean by Ether
um and another fellow came around he uh
said no you're wrong he says ether has
no shape it's pure what potential
either it's just potential whatever that
is okay uh inertial non-spatial
anti-spatial counterpatial negative
spatial hey use all these words that
they throw around you know okay so he
says uh that the first spell is wrong it
cannot be a fluid first guy said it's a
fluid that synchronized says it's not
see they none of these people really
have any idea what the ether is they
just use the word they don't know where
it came from I guess comes the word
ether comes from the Greeks and I
mentioned that the other day or the week
before I don't remember now but ether it
means air
okay it's the heir of the Gods
air made of particles uh molecules atom
whatever you want to put in there okay
so uh
the air that we breathe is made out of
discrete entities right at least that's
the notion we have right and uh the
ether is air but air of the Gods and
when they breathe and so it's also made
out of particles in other words what is
ether a bunch of particles that's the
definition of the word ether now if you
don't like it you say Bill you're wrong
no problem no problem the onus is on you
to point to The Ether if it's an object
if it's a thing that you propose it as a
thing
or if it's a concept then you have to
define it you put the word ether colon
followed by a definition
very easy okay so one or the other
either you define the word ether or you
point to it and by pointing I don't mean
like well we're going to get to that it
says author uh ether is no thing it's
not a thing okay at least this guy says
it's not a thing of which all things are
ether so everything's made out of ether
but ether is not a thing it's like
saying you know air is made out of atoms
uh but the atoms are not a thing
this is more or less with this fellow
saying there is space between two
magnets forcing against each other's
perturbations uh magnetism is a
Divergent force uh Vector that creates
space the loss of pure potential so
they're talking about gaining and losing
potential whatever potential is it's
like money I don't know hopefully
somebody enlightens me but he says ether
cannot be a fluid the first individual
says it is a fluid okay so obviously we
have to get to the bottom of this word
ether because uh apparently all
etherists or proponents of ether have
different ideas what they're proposing
of what The Ether really is okay let's
make sure we understand that there is a
contradiction right now because these
people have different Notions of what
the ether is okay so the first guy comes
back and says either is electricity okay
good it's magnetism uh-huh it's gravity
it's a fluid it's this okay I'm pointing
to a magnet okay so here we have uh my
famous magnets okay
okay there they are okay they stick
together and he says I'm pointing to a
fluid to the to this thing that's
between them right is that I'm pointing
to a magnet okay especially to the space
between two magnets repelling in this
case they're attracting you and I guess
it wouldn't make any difference okay the
point is he he's pointing in between
there okay and he's saying I'm pointing
to the ether or to the counter space or
to whatever's in there field okay the
invisible stuff to the human eye there
that's the either substance
well you haven't pointed all I see that
you're pointing to air okay that's
that's all I see or that I don't see
between the magnets uh what else is
there unless you unless you illustrate
unless you draw it unless you take a
photograph and unless you make a mock-up
of what you propose is between the two
magnets and bring it to the conference
we have no idea what you're talking
about
so the onus is on you to come up and say
look this is The Ether this is what it
looks like if you think it's a thing
because you're saying you're going to
point to it we want to see it without
the magnets get rid of the magnets I
want you to point to The Ether without
the two magnets
okay because if it's a dependent uh
I hope everybody's seen me yet
now they're sending me messages there
from YouTube I have no idea why they do
that just interrupts unnecessarily
anyways let's continue here
um but he says that invisible stuff to
the human eye there that's the ether
substance it's very physical it's a
thing the only way you're going to show
that it's a thing is drawing it
uh making a mock-up of it uh and
illustrate it sketch it we want to see
what it looks like
so that you can point to it okay that's
the way you present objects in physics
now in religion you can do whatever you
want you can print to conscience if you
want we don't care but in physics you
got to point to the object you say rock
you point to a rock and um uh E.T knows
what the word Rock refers to now okay
he's learning your language okay you're
both on an island you point the tree and
say tree so now he knows what a tree is
you know or what the word tree refers to
it's an object a thing it's that thing
you point it to you got to do the same
thing with ether and unless you do that
we have no idea what's going through
your tiny little mind
regarding this word ether okay obviously
you can't see its shape okay we don't
care we don't we're not interested in
seeing the shape of The Ether we want
you to identify the Esther as an object
and if an object is that which has shape
then it's up to you to point put the
object in front of us and say That's The
Ether okay it's not so that we can see
it and touch it that's not the point the
point is so that we know what the word
ether is referring to that's the job
that you have you have to put the object
there now for us to see your touch is so
that we can understand your theory the
one found it on this word that's the
issue okay and they want to avoid that
because no one can point to The Ether
that's the problem and they say well
this is fluid okay yeah but it's still
there like air like water like any other
type of fluid like space even it takes
on the shape containing it okay now you
got to point to it
and just draw it we can draw water we
can draw air you know you just draw
um
a gas and say look that's air or that's
smoke you can do that you know you can
take a snapshot of smoke
and show it and say look that's what I'm
that's what the word smoke refers to and
you if you could you know you could
color code air release it in space and
say look that's air that blob there
okay does it have shape yeah hopefully
it does it's made out of atoms anything
made out of atoms hopefully has shape
because every atom has shape okay you
can't have atoms which have shaved for
me something which doesn't have shape
and that's how you have to do it with
ether you got to point to it and say
that's ether
that's the way that's the only way there
is no other way and if it's a concept
abstract concept not a physical object
like a rock a tree a house no problem
then you have to Define it that's the
only way to do it okay so uh here here
are the subject matters that we're going
to deal with today essentially you know
we have counter space which say bring up
counter space I haven't touched that
word in a long time
um The Ether
been talking so far field and then I'm
going to get into force force at the end
of the show we're going to deal and
that's the subject the prime subject of
today Force okay we're going to get
there but let's go through these other
uh steps first okay
and uh there's a fellow a friend of mine
you know uh from the 15th century
his name was Thomas
and he was famous he was famous because
um he had his office you know his
workshop and this is what it looked like
yeah let me show it to you
good old door Camella and that's what he
would do with uh people who uh disagreed
with him
and I think that's uh you know I would
love to bring turkey mother back to life
again so he could take care of all these
people who talk about you know uh ether
and uh what counter space and field and
all this other nonsense Force
um uh this is uh another shot of his
office okay I guess he would stretch
people a little bit so that they would
grow and especially in knowledge
okay so uh good old turkey Mata I wish I
could get him back to deal with some of
these people who call who think they are
physicists or scientists and they come
up with so much nonsense so much
poppycock okay so here let's go with uh
this let's find out okay so the one
fellow says uh that it's uh fluid and
the other one says it's not a fluid but
here we look at this uh word count
um counter space which is essentially a
synonym of The Ether of field uh they
have these this mix-up where sometimes
they use it as synonym sometimes they
use it as something else this is the
general notion of this counter space
this uh which uh uh this uh what's his
name wheeler uh he he does that on his
channel okay he talks about counter
space and all this other nonsense okay
so what is space space is uh allegedly a
uh where the forces are the physical
forces are you can determine some of
these forces through experiments
observation and measurement the counter
space is like a negative space I guess
it's where the spiritual forces are and
you have conscience the only way to
reach them is through like meditation
it's uh your subliminal experience it's
a totally different world and they want
to look at counter space as a place
where or yeah region in the in the
universe somewhere or maybe in the mind
I have no idea where this counter space
is but it kind of counter uh acts uh
space so it's like in a way the opposite
whereas space has all these physical
forces the counter space has these
spiritual forces and you know they do
merge somewhere in the middle there and
when they merge with some
great things happen according to all
these people all these proponents
okay and um
so here's someone who fella who decided
to illustrate one example this is just
an example okay of what counter space is
as opposed to space okay and so he says
look uh if you look at it from a
geometric point of view space is uh from
a point outwards to Infinity whereas
counter space is from Infinity to a
single point okay so we have Infinity in
both directions except that one's going
down the other one's coming in that's
more or less the notion and it's like uh
the clash between the physical space and
the uh spiritual space if you can try to
understand what I'm saying here I don't
understand what I'm saying so please
don't
hold it against me okay that's more or
less the notion they have of space and
counter space now all I can tell you is
uh what it space and counter space are
for the purposes of physics okay that I
can tell you okay and here it is I
illustrate that as well and here it is
space is that black stuff that's between
the Earth and the moon we call it
nothing vacuum and counter space is uh
where you put your beer on the counter
you know it's the space that's next to
it all around the your mug uh it's the
pla it's all that space that where you
can put more beers you know you can put
a lot of beers in there and that's
called counter space okay so that's all
it is and for the purposes of physics I
hope that's clear okay that's that's all
we have for counter space counter space
is a word that
um
idiots you know uh people with big Ideas
they create these uh things they're
spiritual is there people who are
religious people way deep inside them
and they bring all this garbage into
physics physics is objective and they
bring all this nonsense hey hey we can
merge the spiritual world with a
physical world we can merge physics with
religion you know the Templeton prize so
to speak I guess that's what they're
after
okay so who created this counter space
nonsense okay and here it is it's this
spell called uh by the name of Rudolph
Steiner schneiner he's uh or was a
German uh philosopher or just a
charlatan that's all he was and he's the
inventor of counter space and you can
see what kind of nonsense he uh he wrote
uh some of some of the books he wrote uh
early in the 20th century the
movements in the 19th century the dead
are with us I love that one man uh
hieroglyph uh of the universe an outline
of a quote uh science and uh true and
false pass a spiritual investigation so
you can see that this fella was um into
a lot of nonsense uh he was trying to
merge or try and bring in uh
Consciousness
uh mind all this other stuff that a lot
of religious folks want to bring into
physics and they call themselves
physicists or scientists or whatever
and they bring all that nonsense in here
uh here's uh the article a little piece
of the article on this uh rodolf Steiner
and uh and the Wikipedia says Schneider
attempted to find a synthesis between
science and spirituality his
philosophical work of these years which
he turned spiritual science I love that
sought to apply what he saw as the
clarity of thinking characteristic of
Western philosophy to spiritual
questions okay differentiating this
approach from what he considered to be
vagar approaches to mysticism okay so he
was saying look we can bring science to
Bear upon
the spiritual world and obviously he
meant vice versa right in 1899 Steiner
experienced what he described as a life
transforming inner encounter with the
being of Christ oh my God
okay the experience of meeting Christ
occurred after a tremendous inner
struggle okay he was fighting by
themselves he was you know looking at
the skies and seeing Jesus I guess right
the experience culminated in my standing
in the spiritual presence of the mystery
of Golgotha in a most profound in Salem
Festival of knowledge his relationship
to Christianity thereafter remained
entirely founded upon personal
experience okay he was just giving us
his testimonial that he saw Christ God
or the devil or whoever and he was
bringing that into science and vice
versa applying science as he
understood it to the spiritual world
says hey you know we can put science in
there and understand it more rationally
you know the spiritual world
bestly Christianity and you know gods
and angels and ghosts and who knows what
okay so here um uh one fellow that I
contacted because I usually try to let
them know I'm going to talk about their
uh their uh
uh work uh their blogs whatever their
articles so I usually contact them turns
out this fellow corrected me and said
look you know the guy you mentioned he
just put stuff on my uh site I let him
put him in there but obviously they all
believe in the same thing so I guess in
the end it doesn't matter but this is
what this fellow has to say about
Steiner okay and here it is he says uh
not only does he mention Snyder he
mentions these other folk and the ones
at the bottom uh he didn't mention the
the ones on the bottom right there and
uh those are people who are dissidents
of the establishment uh most of them are
dead now the only one alive is hillster
there at the end and all these people
criticize The Establishment they don't
like what they hear out there see out
there especially anything related to the
word time
they are fanatically against the word
time and anything related to time they
don't like this time dilation they don't
like uh you know anything where you have
space time bending and so on they don't
agree with any of that and of course on
that side we're on the same boat uh the
problem is what these folk always
proposed that's where I have a problem
with all of them and the thought here is
uh Nick Thomas the guy you see there in
approximately uh bottom left okay and uh
the fellow who runs the site is I think
his name is John etch or Eck uh one of
those uh two I don't know how to
pronounce his name exactly but anyways
what does he say about counter space or
these what do they say they say counter
space is a space in which subtle forces
work such as those of Life which are not
amenable to ordinary measurement it is
the polar opposite of what of euclidean
space okay so we're talking about
geometry right so they're going to do
some kind of uh counter part to that it
would discovered by observations of root
of Steiner Etc et cetera okay instead of
having its ideal elements in a plane at
Infinity it has them in a point at
Infinity
there are lines and planes rather than
lines and points as in ordinary space
okay we call this point the counter
space Infinity uh-huh
we have the counter space Infinity I
hope you're following along so that a
plane incident with it is said to be an
ideal plane or plane at Infinity in
counter space it only appears thus for a
different kind of Consciousness namely a
peripheral one Which experiences such a
point as an infinite inwardness in
contrast to our normal Consciousness
Which experiences an infinite
outwardness again it's like uh outwards
and inwards that's what it's all about
the space counter space it's like uh the
opposite of space you have space and you
see it outwards and goes to Infinity
that's that's the way they look at it
right they say oh it's Infinite Space
isn't of course it's not because it's
absolutely nothing nonsense to treat
space as a physical object and the only
way you can apply the word infinite or
finite is to a physical object you can
say the uh the uh tree is finite and
hopefully it's not infinite there is no
such thing as an infinite object because
all objects are finite because that's
the definition of the word uh
that which has shape all shapes are
finite and these people invented
something new they said look it's the
counter space
aha what do you mean by that well
instead of looking outwards you know to
the Infinity of this space or thingy or
whatever they have in their back of
their minds they say we got to look at
an introspective the inwards to a point
from Infinity to a point or through an
infinite point right and um and so they
they kind of merge okay you have the
outward vision and the inward Vision but
the inward vision is all
from conscience from personal experience
okay uh you know you have to take a lot
of drugs to do this kind of thing if I
were getting to that okay so what did
this uh Nick Thomas say he says the
following he says uh he calls it The
Ether Force counter space research he
does research on this stuff great
research is only truly spiritual when
it's related to what lies on the other
side of that threshold
okay so you got to get to the other side
to really experience this uh counter
space stuff okay it says our
Consciousness on this side of the
threshold is objective to cross the
threshold requires a kind of inversion
inversion of Consciousness to the
research concerns the inversion of
Consciousness in relation to counter
space for application to science
yeah you got to invert your
Consciousness uh I don't know exactly
how to do that how do you
in order to understand counter space you
got to do a counter Consciousness you
got to leave it from the outside in and
invert yourself stand on your head I
have no idea in fact one one of the
fellows out there said the following he
said I love this one bill please
consider doing psychedelics if you
haven't already
based on hearing others others
experiences you might be able to expand
on your theories in a major way yeah
um uh I've never did any drugs in my
life uh even marijuana I don't do any
drugs at all I don't even smoke never
smoked in my life uh I only do two drugs
and that's uh beer and wine and
sometimes I get a schnapps a uh rum or
something like that you know but
otherwise I don't touch any of the drugs
in fact when I was uh detained arrested
and they took me into this
um to the prison to the jail in uh
Maricopa jail county jail in Phoenix and
uh the first shock that I had in prison
was seeing this guy with holes all over
his arms and legs he had just holes
everywhere there was there was not an
inch not a centimeter without a hole in
his legs and in his arms he just all his
life he just did drugs just putting that
needle in there he had no place no the
same place to put a new needle into and
that shocked me to see a guy like that
now when they uh transferred me uh to uh
the Santa Clara jail in California
and uh first day I was there you know I
was waiting for them to book me and uh
one of the cops was there and and I saw
this guy on the floor he was just
shaking you know and I was and I looked
at him I said like you know this guy
needs help you know please get a doctor
or something you know so I said to the
cop I said uh what's wrong with him and
just a matter of fact you know casual
you said oh don't worry about him he's
recovering from heroin withdrawal
and then I found two more guys inside
the prison uh that also were recovering
and so it's kind of nasty stuff I don't
recommend people doing drugs at all
especially some of those hard drugs
is uh once again I bring my good fellow
torkemara I wish uh he would be around
for some of these folks so that uh you
know he would do a good job with him
okay
okay uh moving on here
uh here we have The Ether now okay and
this is what these fellows said okay one
says neither is a fluid like any other
type of fluid okay and the other fellow
says no it cannot be a fluid so we have
a fight of the etherus here we have two
different versions of What the ether is
okay and the first thing I want to point
out is here this and that's that
a field I'm sorry a fluid is a liquid
gas or other material that's what the
word fluid means okay and they are
substances and you look at these words
you look them up and all these are from
Wikipedia by the way liquid and fluid so
we have a circular argument if a fluid
is a liquid and liquid is a fluid we
haven't understood anything what is gas
it's made out of atoms and molecules and
what is a substance everyday objects
that can be touched ultimately composed
of atoms okay so uh is this foul saying
the guy who says that it's a fluid is he
saying that
um it's made out of atoms or molecules
uh hopefully not and I don't think he
would say that but then he's got to tell
us what the ether is he's got to point
to it and say That's The Ether like he
would point to a rock say look that's a
rock that's a tree that's a house that's
how he's got to do it and uh he said no
he I'm gonna point between two magnets
and you know that invisible stuff that's
there that's the ether that's the
counter space that's the field
it doesn't work that way sorry guy you
know especially when the field the
counter space The Ether all this stuff
um they're infinite as I discussed the
other day
the official version okay is that a
field extends forever even Beyond Space
Nine you know this field is infinite
that's the way they Define it you don't
like the definition you got to define
the word field you got to define the
word ether you got to define the word
counter space you can't just go in there
and say I'm pointing to it now all you
did is point to the air which we can't
see either okay you point it to nothing
if you want to point to something you
got to put the shape in front of our
eyes then we know that you are pointing
to something
Gotta Have shape that's the definition
of object shape not C touch okay
okay
um in a second here
okay uh so you look up you know
everything
um that is an object a thing a substance
body whatever you want all these are
synonyms entity right they're all
synonyms okay in physics they all mean
the same exact thing not like in uh
ordinary speech where they have some
variation between them in physics it's
either hair shape or it don't
it's black or white it's yes or no on or
off there's no middle ground okay if God
wants to be an object he's got to have
shape otherwise he's a concept love
intelligence whatever you want to call
it that's what you're praying to to
intelligence to love to you know
whatever you have to uh data okay so you
got a point and uh the problem is nobody
has defined the word object in the last
10 000 years and that's kind of strange
and uh kind of eye-opening because see
um physics cannot be done without
announcing you need to have an object to
do physics and by that I mean you know
uh what is happening if there are no
objects in the universe you know God
comes in there and he raises everything
from the universe including energy field
whatever you want to think of he just
leaves emptiness what we call space
nothing right he leaves nothing there
what's happening
uh what's occurring what's moving what
experiments can you run what are you
observing
so you can't do physics without objects
physics starts with objects that's the
starting point and so if it starts with
object the first word you need to Define
in physics is the word object you can't
do physics without defining the word
object you absolutely need to do that
and nobody has done so in the last 10
000 years not a single textbook of
physics Begins by defining the word
object so that the student for example
at the high school level says okay I
know what an object is now we can talk
about motion right because we're going
to say okay the object moves we can talk
about anything you want work you know
you can put out any concept you want but
the first thing the starting point is
object you can't do anything without an
object the Earth is an object so if
you're going to talk about the orbit of
the earth you had better treat Earth as
an object for that you need to know what
the word object refers to
okay and what's our issue here's uh the
stack exchange one prominent site okay
and someone asked the question he says
um when does something become a
mathematical object okay it says math
Scholars have told me that mathematical
objects are used to represent numbers in
general uh matrices Etc however a matrix
is considered an array where does this
premise reach a concrete definition if
arrays can be in fact numerical
why is an RNA considered different than
a number if they can both be the exact
same thing it seems math is quite shaky
in my introspection of varying angles of
the subject therefore I ask this why
should I take something serious Beyond
Elementary logic participles if it has
no Clarity distinction of properties or
common sense
okay so the guy asked the question this
is what he wants to know he says uh has
multiple meanings you know he said this
word object okay so what is an object
and one guy answered the only guy I
really that made a little bit of sense
which made no sense really whatsoever
what he did is essentially avoid the
question and he answered this follow
says mathematics is exactly the opposite
of shaking you gotta set there someone
touching his uh discipline uh you're
the foundation of mathematics are very
concrete and precise some some things
like the word object are not rigorously
defined because the meaning very so much
from one context to the next however
it's not strictly important what the
meaning of the word is there is a no
mathematics that is based on the meaning
of that word
see so he's saying
you know mathematics is just equations
and he's right but the problem is
mathematical physics that's a different
specialty where they introduce
mathematics and they shove it into
physics even though mathematics has
absolutely nothing to do with physics
physics is about explaining how the
world works qualitatively and math is
describing it quantitatively these are
two different disciplines and they try
to merge them in something called
mathematical physics and that's the way
this guy said well the word object
doesn't belong in math it belongs
somewhere else maybe in philosophy
ontology who knows where that's that's
what he's saying okay it's an informal
term informal term that allows uh
mathematicians to convey General notion
things that do matter are always clearly
and precisely defined okay yeah things
that do matter and obviously none of the
qualitative terms
um are defined in mathematics
mathematics and when I say mathematics I
mean mathematical physics we don't care
about mathematics the discipline of
mathematics we care about this religion
known as mathematical physics where they
try to merge mathematics with physics
and call it mathematical physics so they
bring an equation and they say we're
going to interpret it for you and this
is the physical interpretation the
qualitative physical interpretation this
is the meaning the
um uh you know the physical
interpretation this is what this is how
the universe works that's what they
claim to be able to say from an equation
that's where the problem comes in
because the explanation they give for
invisible intangible phenomena and
objects is totally bunk it's total
nonsense papika you know none of it
survives uh whatever they did in the
last hundred years Quantum mechanic
general relativity string theory none of
that other is garbage nonsense because
they're physical interpretations are
totally irrational what's irrational to
move a concept whether they move they
move energy they move field they move
forces we will say today uh they move
ether some of them
dissidents usually they move waves
wave packets
they move particles which ain't
particles what's a particle it's a
number so they're moving a number with a
value you know a value with a unit
so they're moving Concepts all around
they're transferring energy moving the
mass
shaking the field that's all irrational
nonsense papika that's what mathematical
physics is all about and that's why it
has nothing to do with physics or with
science none of it none of it all of it
dies uh immediately and um someone one
of the fellows over there at the uh our
rational science group uh he put the
word object in the chat GPT to find out
what the what the robot will tell us
about the word object and it turns out
the robot came on my side hey you know
they got one right for a chance for
finally you know here it is it says um
see if I can read there'd be so little
it says an object essentially is that
which has a boundary
well it's close enough they're saying
it's that which has shape okay that's
what we say this the chat GPT said it's
a boundary uh we can grant it to them so
what is an object that which I shaped
that which has a boundary you know I
guess we can go with that one as a close
approximation yeah that's what an object
is and um nobody has ever figured that
out nobody even uses that definition
everybody uses the seed touch notion of
object that in objects that which you
can see an object that which you can
touch if you can't see it and touch it's
not an object
well you can't see the air is that an
object well some people say it ain't
and uh you know uh like I say can you
touch the table on the other side of the
universe or on the other side of our
planet
and the answer is no you can't touch it
or see it so isn't the table an object
the word table does not represent an
object always
or the word chair
yeah hopefully a rock is a word that
always represents an object whether it's
on the other side of the universe or
here or right in front of you
why because it has shape not because you
can see it or touch it so to see touch
criteria is irrational we cannot use
that in physics so how do we do it in
physics well you want to know what a
rock is you point to it put your finger
there and point to a rock and say rock
now the ET understands what you're
talking about he says okay I can relate
to your uh to your thing okay I know
what the Rock word Rock means okay
here's another one uh you want to know
what a house is you point to it and say
look it's a house okay Point that's how
it's done
okay here you have uh another word table
are you learning something learning how
to how to present objects in physics you
point to them and say Table Rock chair
tree whatever so how do you present The
Ether well you gotta point to it okay
here it is give me a second here I went
to the other side I guess give me a
second here
you point to it you have to point and
say ether That's The Ether what are you
going to point to
okay that's the question what are you
going to put in there just like I put a
rock I put a tree uh house a table chair
whatever
what are you gonna put for ether
that's the question that's a million
dollar question for you if you cannot
put an object there you cannot or
something or a sketch or whatever then
you cannot treat it as an object
okay so unless you can put something
right there in front of that finger
okay then you do not know what ether is
you cannot give us a piece of your mind
pull it out here and put it there and
say look this is what I have in my mind
that's what the ether is that's what I'm
referring to every time I wear I use the
word ether
if you can't do that ether is not a
physical object
very simple it's got to be static it
can't be moving okay moving is a movie
that's a dynamic concept you have to
point to something that is static not
moving and say That's The Ether and in
the same way you point and say
that's a field
what are you going to point to it's got
to be enclosed all around it's got to be
shape all around and you can't have uh
the two magnets there or something else
it's got to be all by itself standalone
okay
objects stand alone I don't need to have
um a tree next to a rock to know where
the rock is or what a tree is
I can point to a tree I can put to a
rock all by themselves I don't need to
have something else nearby to compare it
or whatever to fool me or whatever it's
not a dependent object in that sense
okay and likewise the field cannot be
dependent on anything else it's got to
be Standalone then it's an option if it
depends on something else it's not an
object it's a concept game people don't
understand that takes 10 years for one
of these uh etheris uh
counter-specialists to understand what
an object is and that's kindergarten
physics if you haven't if you don't know
what an object is you haven't gone
through kindergarten in physics so you
much less do we want to listen to your
theories because First Years could be
poppycock it's going to be nonsense I
mean you got to start by understanding
what an object is what a thing is and it
takes 10 years for some of these people
to understand it some of them never grab
it in their whole life
okay so um some people say well what is
the shape of water or is water an object
what is the shape of uh air what is you
know it's it's constantly moving it from
one second to the next they get all uh
you know they go into rabbit holes and
they get lost in there they don't
understand what the issue is how to
present an object that's where 10 years
for these people to understand what a
thing is where the purposes of physics
and we can't do physics without a thing
okay so let's keep all that in mind okay
so here it is uh we have the astronaut I
showed the other day and he releases a
blob of liquid it could be a water it
could be something whatever does that
have shape
and the question is not what is the
shape of the question is does it have
shame it's a yes or no type of question
does it have to say hopefully the answer
is yes unless you're blind I don't know
so uh both the um astronaut and this
blob both have shape okay that's the way
you present an object in physics
okay and so yeah water does have shape
and air does have shape as well like
um here on Earth you know Earth uh the
air covers the entire Earth
so you can get rid of the earth and what
you have is this shell and that's air
that's the shape of air around the earth
you can also blow into a balloon air
hopefully color coded and have the
astronaut you know release it in in
space like he did with a water there
with the bubble there and or block right
he punctures the uh the balloon and
suddenly you have all this color-coded
air into block you know it's an
irregular shape blob does that blob have
shape
and he answers hopefully yes yeah that
whole blob will call it air and that
blob whatever shape it has it has shape
so yeah anything made out of atoms
hopefully has shaped because all atoms
have shape I don't know of any atom that
doesn't and I don't know of any object
that does not have shape so if you know
of one hey please put it in the comments
section I'll address it for sure so if
you can find one object any object you
can think of that doesn't have shape hey
I'll buy you a beer
uh not not uh marijuana I'll do it with
you okay so this is what I did the other
day I showed that um when you put ether
in the um what is it in the Google
search for images you get all these
things this is what appeared when I put
them in there you probably do it again
and get something similar in other words
no one has the slightest idea what the
ether is they have all these different
shapes different ideas what the ether is
you go into any of these sites and
you'll get a different answer in each
one they try to explain to you what the
ether is you know in in science we do
not learn physics right we do not
explain what an object is we point to it
period if you can't do that it's not
it's not an option and these people
can't point to The Ether they never
figured out what the ether is you know
they have these vague Notions as you can
see one guy said it's fluid the other
one says it ain't it's potential
whatever okay so here's so so I can show
you that nobody has any idea what the
ether is I just showed you they have all
these Notions now I'm going to show you
what the ether is what it's always been
since the days of the Greek okay uh you
know uh Plato and all these folks and
this is what it is a bunch of particles
this is ether that you always wanted to
know about okay so there's The Ether
that's the one they were thinking of in
the 19th century when we're D when they
were dealing with the ether and what
were they saying were they saying that
if um if the ether vibrates and you get
these waves
okay and so they were trying to figure
out light and they said it's the
movement it's the shaking of The Ether
what is ether a bunch of particles
that's all it was that's all it's ever
been and uh that's not a thing it's a
concept okay because first of all uh
many particles you know or many trees
Forest is a concept it's not a thing
many children you know many people
multitude it's constant it's not a theme
okay and likewise you know many
particles uh
uh if that's what the ether is it's it's
not a thing uh table there's also many
particles so is everything in the
universe you know many particles so you
can't say oh I'm pointing to many
particles
no you gotta point to a shape
we got to see what it looks like you
know all around okay then we understand
what you're referring to okay it's not a
question of seed touch okay let's get
that straight it's an issue that you
have to tell us what your ether is what
your uh counter space is or field or
whatever
so you have to tell the audience what it
is
okay it's a field
that's uh the word that everybody loves
everybody loves the word feel like the
word energy because they can get away
with murder because they can say
whatever they want they can say energy
and people say oh okay I know what
you're talking about
and then you look at him nobody can
Define the word energy they say well
there's many types of energy and we
don't know exactly what it is but let's
use it let's use the word
it don't work that way in physics
physics you have to point to it so if
you don't talk about energy point to
energy I want to see what what it is so
that I can follow your presentation and
likewise with the word field you know
you say field no problem point to it
okay and so uh it turns out that someone
asked the question over there in um at
the stack exchange also again prominence
physics site where all these
mathematical physics and mathematical
physics okay and uh and uh you know and
so these people ask a question here and
again remember the the two flowers that
were arguing there so one file says the
ether is electricity it's magnetism okay
I'm going to I'm pointing to a main
especially just to the space between two
magnets repelling in this case they're
attracting but it's the same thing so
he's saying he points here and that's
the field okay counter space ether they
use all these synonyms for the same
nonsense okay that invisible stuff to
the human and I are there that's the
ether substance and that's also the
field right he's pointing to a field the
other fellow says fields are movies yeah
it's something in motion okay uh you
gotta but it's not the field that's the
object field is the region where an
object is moving in which an object is
moving okay you've got to identify the
object that is moving in the region
known as field
these people don't understand that they
treat the field as a physical object
okay and again that's that's absolute
nonsense there's space between two
magnets forcing against each other uh
perturbation magnetism is what a
Divergent Force Vector that creates
space creates space the loss of space
potential uh the the loss of pure
potential so they're talking about
nonsense if any in these uh terms like
counter space potential you know what is
all that what are they referring to
and uh the Stag exchange like I was
saying uh here that someone asked that
question says is a field a physical
object and he closed the question nobody
can put any more uh comments there okay
and the guy asked I think a decent
question is a field of physical object
and they didn't like the question they
said it it amounted to opinions in the
end and so they said well we're going to
shut this question down so the important
questions they shut down they said no we
want to do math only we want to talk
about you know uh numbers and units and
equations and so when you ask a question
you know as a field of physical object
they don't like that question yeah they
alluded it because they're they call
themselves mathematical physics because
they're not physicists they're not
scientists they're mathematical
physicists and then when you ask them
okay how does this universe uh work uh
is a field and object is energy an
object is it a thing and they say well
that's not a question you should ask us
go ask a English major or you know a
librarian or whatever they send you
somewhere else to the other side of
Campus of the philosophers the
ontologists they say they do that so
they use the word in physics which they
call physic mathematical physics but
they they expect the philosophers on the
other side of campus to define the words
forum
you see what's happening so they say oh
you want to know what an object is go to
the other side of Campus they'll tell
you what it is okay so they have people
who have no stake in it they're finding
the words for the discipline of
so-called physics
okay uh let's go to Mr Faraday and
Maxwell they should know a little better
uh they did a lot of study on this stuff
and um what did uh Faraday have to say
he said I cannot conceive of curved
lines of force without the conditions of
a physical existence in network
intermediate space okay the space is
what is known as field it's a space it's
a region region is a concept
not a thing
and he's saying the lines of force are
what we have to identify that's the
physical object that's moving in there
and Maxwell said something similar says
feel the space right the region in the
neighborhood of the electric and
magnetic bodies in that space in that
region right there is matter in motion
it's the matter in motion that you have
to identify what matter is moving inside
the so-called region called field
and there you see something is moving in
that region it's not static it brings
two magnets together and uh so it's the
lines of force that you have to identify
what are those lines of force
you know something is moving there and
it's those lines of force or they create
lines of force that's how we see them
with iron filings but something is
moving there and so it's that which you
have to uh identify
and these people never did they just
used the word field and say oh the field
does this moves the charge and does all
these good things and in the case of
um gravity they say okay one planet
pulls on another on the moon uh with a
field
now field is a region of numbers that's
all a field the word field means it's
not a it's not a thing it's a concept
you can't say the field does this the
field does that because field is a
concept Concepts don't move things
around don't move tables around you
can't say the field move the Earth
around
where the field move I don't know pencil
around can't do that in physics that's
irrational that's an irrational physical
interpretation you can't use the word
field in science you can't use the word
energy in science or the word mass
especially as physical objects you can't
say the mass does this now
you have to put an object there a thing
you say the tree does this The Rock does
this then we can understand but you
can't say mass does this that's a
mathematical concept okay
but nobody reads Faraday unfortunately
and that's where all these people should
start they should read Verde because
Verde even though he had a lot of things
wrong he
I mean he was a Pioneer so he was just
starting out so I think he laid the
foundations for other people who came
after to improve on what he did and
nobody did because today we still have
no idea at least any of these folks from
mathematical physics they have no idea
what a field is or what energy is or
what mass is they don't care because
they're going to do numbers they just
use the values okay and that's where the
problem is they don't pay attention to
what it is because that's a qualitative
thing and they don't do qualitative
stuff except when they want to explain
for you give your physical
interpretation of how this universe
works then they say oh we have authority
because we're mathematicians that's
where the problem is okay so here it is
uh if you would have read uh Faraday he
would have told you says um
it may be asked what lines of force are
there is what lines of force are there
in nature which are fitted to convey
such an action and supply for the
vibrating Theory the place of The Ether
okay he's asking a rhetorical question
he's going to answer he says I do not
pretend to answer this question with any
confidence in other words he has no clue
okay all I can say is that I do not
perceive in any part of space whether
vacant or filled with matter anything
but forces and the lines in which they
are exerted so the lines are exerting
meaning the lines are physical it's the
lines that are physical not the field
not the region it's the lines
I don't know if that got sunk in
anybody's head out there it's the lines
you have to identify there's something
physical there and those lines are
people say well we only use them to
explain something no no those lines are
real there's something there
okay if it's moving if it's like Maxwell
says some exotic manner that's moving in
there it's those lines those are the
ones you got to identify what are those
lines
The View which I am so bold to put forth
considers therefore a radiation
um as a kind of species of vibration in
the lines of force which are known to
connect particles lines of force which
are known to connect particles okay we
have particles there connected
physically connected by something there
which are these lines of force and also
masses of matter together The Ether lies
between the particles because he had no
idea what the ether is he had to use
this word which was famous in those days
right and so carries on the vibrations
okay it is by the lines of force between
the centers of the particles that the
vibration is continued vibration moves
along the lines of force it's the lines
of force which are vibrating lines of
force are a physical entity hopefully
because only a physical entity can
vibrate Concepts don't vibrate
okay we got that okay so that's how he
started but he continued because he was
talking about interconnectedness
physical interconnectedness he says I
inclined to believe that when there are
intervening particles of matter being
themselves only centers of force right
they take part in carrying on the force
through the line
okay it's the line the line of force is
the one that you know there's a physical
entity there that's vibrating that's
doing something only things can do
things okay but that when there are none
the line proceeds through space so the
lines are still there
for supposed two bodies A and B distant
from each other and under mutual action
and therefore connected by lines of
Force if one of the bodies move in the
least degree right or left or if its
power be shifted for a moment within the
mass then an effect equivalent to a
lateral disturbance will take place in
the resultant upon which we are fixing
our attention
uh he just explained entanglement and
he's saying there's something there
entanglement does not proceed like the
mathematicians say to they which is by
action at a distance you know spirits
and ghosts and God no there's a line of
force there between two objects and it
connects the two object let me repeat
that it's a physical entity that
connects an elongated physical entity
that connects to particles okay for
either it will increase in force will
the neighboring results are diminishing
or it will fall in force as they are
increasing the occurrence of a change at
one end of a line of force easily
suggests a consequent change at the
other
uh he he what he did uh there is talk
about uh what is known as entanglement
he already had discovered the
entanglement you know 100 years before
Einstein and epr and all these other
people
uh so he already knew there was
something there okay and he knew it was
something he just couldn't explain it he
didn't understand what it was but he
says there's a physical entity there
it's a line of force and that's the one
that vibrates that's when we have to
identify not the field the field is is a
bunch of lines of force
that's what a field is field is a region
and it's not even that it's a today it's
a region of numbers of values
strengths how much strength uh there is
at different points along this so-called
field in this region that's how it is
and they turned it into a physical
object okay uh so
so what are what is that field you know
what are these lines of force
and here it is okay we've shown this
here you have two magnets and the lines
of force are these threads that are
moving
you know in One Direction and the other
if they both are moving clockwise then
you have attraction on the top and
criminal clockwise on the bottom you
have attraction and if you have been
reverse clockwise versus
counterclockwise well then you have uh a
repulsion and to do that you just got to
turn the magnet around 180 degrees very
simple and that's what the lines of
force are they're just swinging threads
okay and
um so you know the question is you know
people say well where do these threads
arise and uh so that's when we have to
show this uh the famous
um wave is not really a wave it's a rope
that's twirling in place so it's not a
wave which is a bunch of vectors okay
mathematical vectors that move from A to
B in One Direction it's a rope trolling
in situ and it's the threads of that
rope that are going to be swinging
around and creating magnetism attraction
and repulsion so the Rope is a thing
it's not a concept the thread is a thing
you want to know what a thread is for
those of you who do not know uh ask your
grandmother for a needle uh with a
thread and she'll know what to give you
and that thread that's what it is that's
what it looks like it's a thread
continuous Red made of a single piece
what is a wave well wave is just a bunch
of vectors that travel one way a road
travels two ways you know that's that's
the advantage of a rope okay so yeah
they've confused a rope and that's what
they've been analyzing for the last 150
years almost 200 years they've been
looking at a rope you know
they've been looking at a rope and they
say oh waves
yeah and uh they shake them up and down
you know
yeah so there is no such thing as a wave
wave is a concept you know water is is
an object wave is what it does you can't
say the wave waves the water waves it's
the flag that way it's not the wave that
waves okay but they turn turn wave into
a physical object and they said Oh The
Wave waves
okay
okay and here you see the difference
between them okay mathematical physics
they have this field which is a concept
uh and two Fields make up a wave and for
some reason they travel at 90 degrees to
each other nobody knows why
and they move only one way and what
you're staring at is a bunch of arrows
and those arrows are just vectors what
is a vector magnitude and direction
so all you have there is a mathematical
nonsense poppycock that the
mathematicians invented all the way
since the days of good old Verity
what do we propose instead well we
propose that what they've been looking
at all these years is a rope to a
two-strand rope twine against each other
just like DNA okay that's more or less
what it is in fact DNA very likely
inherited or or has its structure
because
um you know it's the code of the
universe yeah the rope-like
um strand you know double stranded rope
that's the code of the universe and DNA
essentially imitated that same
architecture so what we're looking at is
a rope and not a wave okay and they
never figure that out and yeah if you
um want to see why uh Maxwell was right
about
threads and about something physical
moving in the region we call field well
I've shown this several times but it
doesn't hurt to show it one more time
and that's that if you put a magnet
underwater and you have all these iron
filings there they will gradually
gradually and in a given order right
approach the magnet something is
twirling in that region we call field
field is not the object it's whatever
squirting in there twirly in there
that's what's pulling each iron filing
up towards the magnet and it's done uh
gradually as you can see there okay
so something is swinging there something
is moving and that's something is what
you have to identify we say it's the
threads
and it better be an object okay it's or
like a good old Maxwell said it's a
matter in motion it's some exotic kind
of matter obviously we can't see it or
touch it the iron filings can touch it
at least not see it but we can't and so
all we can do is look and say okay the
iron filing is seeing something or
feeling something and what is that
something well it's these threads that
are moving around at Great speeds
pulling each one of the iron filings up
towards the magnet that's what it is
okay so uh here we have our
interconnected Universe this is uh water
okay this is what water looks like all
the atoms and molecules are
interconnected you know they're they've
got all these connections there okay
they call them hydrogen bonds uh because
they have no other way of describing
them no they're a thread I'm sorry there
are ropes okay the Rope we have a twined
rope there connecting any two atoms okay
so all molecules there are connected by
ropes
and that's what water is okay
they're all connected all atoms in the
universe are physically connected now uh
you might say uh you know if you want to
explain magnets uh
uh you know you got to identify
whatever's in there and people say well
I can't see it I don't know what it
looks like well you know you have to
make an assumption about what's in there
you can say Well they're angel
and someone might say well I don't
believe in angels
but we don't care if you do or not we
want to understand what's going through
your head and if you propose that there
are angels well no problem let's see
explain your theory okay so I explained
that and angels on one side of the man
and another Angel's on the other side on
another magnet and they pull on each
other and that's how they produce
attraction and then when they play patty
cake you know they push each other away
do you believe in angels we don't care
we're trying to understand the theory
that the guy proposes okay another
fellow says anything I can do with um
you know with uh two uh hooks
when the hooks are like that you know
they pull and when they're like that
they push and so we have attraction and
repulsion do you believe in hooks but we
don't care if you do or not we're trying
to understand the theory the mechanism
that you propose okay so in order to
understand the mechanism mechanism needs
objects right you can't do it without an
object you say it's The Ether you say
it's the counter space you say it's a
field no problem you can name it call it
X
we don't care the name is unimportant we
need for you to point to the object and
then explain the mechanism with the
object you pointed to that's the way it
works in physics if you can't do that if
you can't Point first to the object you
have nothing to teach
you can only learn you're still haven't
gone through kindergarten physics that's
where you're at okay so uh don't come
here and tell me that you know
everything and then this is how it works
with the ethereum with this counter
space in with a field until you can
point to any of those words that you use
you know what they mean either you
define them or you point to them if
they're if you think they're an object
or you propose them as an object
okay and so this leads to force because
what is this um
what it what are two main they say well
there's a force there like uh
um Richard Feynman they asked him about
marriage when there's a force there and
I cannot explain it any better of course
he could not explain it because the only
way you're going to explain is
identifying the object that's in there
then you can explain it and Rich uh you
know good old Dicky Feynman you know he
had no clue he had no clue he was he was
not a teacher you don't teach when when
you have nothing to teach when you're
when you do math Fizz and you have
learned anything other than uh equations
then you have nothing to teach except
equations but when you try to do physics
you know the math Fizz part the physical
part that's when you run into trouble
because everyone I cannot explain with
in words in real words in qualitative
words then you don't know it or like
Einstein allegedly said you don't know
well enough if you cannot explain it to
a bar maid right and that's where all
these people were
okay so uh what is this thing called
Force well uh apparently uh the
mathematicians in the last
50 years at least a little more really
um discovered four forces just like the
four horses of the Apocalypse they
discovered four forces okay what are
these horses well we go to a prominent
site and that's uh Eric weinsteins and
uh the Wolfram site right and uh they
have all the information you need if you
want to do math Fizz and I just want to
point out that there's four forces the
strong the electromagnetic weak and
gravitational and they have what what
they call Carrier we have the carrier of
a force okay and what they they do is uh
you know they put have this little ball
that carries interactions it carry verbs
okay and when the carrier for the strong
force is the gluon it mediates you know
between uh two quarks elicity pulls them
together how it does that I don't know
because if it's a particle you wonder
how it carries the forest of Attraction
whatever that means okay
Photon the photons the particle of the
electromagnetic force otherwise known as
light okay and then we have the uh bozos
we have the bozos the clowns and that's
the weak force of W's and Z's okay and
then famous graviton which they're still
trying to figure out they've never were
able to pinpoint the graviton and they
never will because there is no such
particles at graviton but they want to
explain attraction by throwing a little
ball known as a graviton how do you do
that
and yeah they say that delivers negative
momentum so instead of uh pushing you
away it delivers negative motion towards
you
uh you can do anything in math it is
okay okay so here are each one of these
uh particles okay the forces here's the
strong forces the strong fourth which
binds the nucleons in the nucleus and of
course with the nucleons in other words
it's the the this strong force is inside
the nucleus of the atom
and what it does it keeps the quarks
together that form the neutrons and um
and the protons okay so that's their job
and what you'll see is something where
they cheat because they have this
particle
this gluon and it stretches
it stretches and they always
Illustrated as a bubble gum you know the
stretch bubble gum or uh you know
what is it a bedroom a bed spring
so they have to stretch it to show that
there's this uh tension you know between
the corks yeah they have to do something
like that they have to put a uh an
elongated object between the two quarks
because otherwise they cannot show how
one Quark physically attracts another
and so they always stretch the quad and
they put it as a bed spring or bubble
gum or who knows what
okay so that's the that's the glue on
the strong force okay now here's the um
what is it the electromagnetic force
says um you know it's a
infinite range attractive or repulsive
Force which acts between charged
particles so it looks like uh the
electromagnetic also is repulsive Force
okay according to these people and uh
they see them as particles the photon is
the representative is the carrier of
this interaction and you'll see a lot of
that in the uh finding space-time
diagrams they always talk about that
nonsense there they like to put that's
what he got his Nobel Prize for by the
way the the nonsense of space-time
diagrams okay and then we have the weak
force and that uh it says it transforms
an uh up Quark to a down Court you know
so it changes a proton to a neutron and
vice versa I guess right so that's the
this Force this particle a w a z I don't
know what it looks like never seen one
of these particles they they never
Illustrated any other particles in the
standard model so you have to use your
own imagination what they look like or
whether they have shape because they're
really not talking about you know
they're not talking about a little ball
they represent it with a little ball but
immediately they go and talk about the
energy and the uh you know the speed and
the size and the mass and charge and all
that other stuff they don't talk about
what does it look like
well it's a particle bill you know it
looks looks like this like a like a
little ball that's what it looks like
yeah very simple okay
um and then the last one here we have
the graviton okay and what is the
graviton well they're still looking for
it but it's some kind of ball okay that
produces attraction between at least uh
you know in this world I guess uh why a
pen falls to the floor I guess the floor
throws gravitons on it they don't like
to use the graviton uh for space stuff
you know Cosmic stuff that's when they
replace that with space-time okay
because if they put particles there you
know they would have a lot of trouble
explaining you know the
um mechanism to a Layman and or even to
themselves so they don't use it there
okay here we have um the problem one of
the problems there with all these
particles is that they all travel one
way okay the electromagnetic rabbiton
gluon and wz bozos they all travel one
way and that's already a handicap
because you know in order for you to
have uh
you know um some kind of interaction the
other guy has to shoot the same particle
in the opposite direction hopefully the
particles don't a force right don't
Collide and uh one has to shoot at the
other so
how that produces attraction is the
problem because we can understand forces
forces like the photon which is an
outward force it always goes out no
problem there uh push and then we have
um uh what is it the uh
weak Force also a push it goes outwards
but the gluon and graviton are pull
forces they they pull things in they
they produce attraction that's their job
that's what they're supposed to do how
do you do that with a discrete particle
how do you throw a stone and have the
dog come towards you right that's that's
the question and now you're gonna have
trouble with a mechanism that's why they
can't explain at least the graviton and
in the case of the glue on they cheat
they put a bubble gum or a bed spring
okay so here we have uh one of the
issues that uh Wolfram brought up in a
Weinstein and Eric Weinstein and what
does he say he says look
um
there's also a fifth Force
so we had uh pull push
perhaps maybe and now we have
um
I don't know what what the fifth one is
but to call the fifth one they call it
the fifth Force okay that's good enough
and so they say yeah that
um they said there are some things that
they cannot explain uh some movements
there that require a fifth force that is
not one or the other four and so they
say well maybe there is a fifth force
and they're going to do an investigation
and remember this came out in 1996 so
since then they've been looking for this
fifth fourth I don't know if anybody
ever worked on this okay but they
mentioned it at the time you know we're
talking about almost 30 years ago right
and a few days ago they went with his
fifth force that I talked about the
other day but this is a different type
of fifth for it this has to do with the
muon okay it's got a little wobble that
they cannot explain and now this is a
hot item right now everybody's looking
for this fifth Force okay they're trying
to try to verify it so that they can win
a Noble Prize you know so they say oh we
found a wit fifth for us and it's the
force that produces the wobble in the
muon which is unexplained by any other
Force yeah that's more or less their
reasoning so they keep inventing all
these forces okay so what does uh
Weinstein say that a force is I mean
what is a force okay and so he goes in
there and he says look a force is a push
or pull
okay we're gonna stop there pull period
point
okay it's a push or a pull that's it
that's all you know the only type of
interactions that we can imagine okay so
uh if you have contact with something
you either push or pull it there is no
other uh form of contact that we can
imagine
so how do they come up with four forces
that they're all particles
right and they all move one way so we
cannot produce attraction because they
all move in the opposite direction to to
attraction right
and he says it's a pool or a push that's
only two forces how do they end up with
four
so we got a little bit of problem
because there's a mismatch there he's
telling us that it's push or pull and
then he comes up and says oh there's
four forces
so one thing doesn't match with the
other okay so we say okay what is a
particle I mean if if I mean how do you
represent the force with a particle
anyways but they say it's the particle
of force and we call this this one the
particle known as the graviton the other
one is the photon the other one is the
gluon they're all particles and they
carry forces
carry interaction they carry verbs on
their shoulder okay so what is a
particle okay so we look it up and says
the particle is a small localized object
object it's a thing okay we got it no
problem what's a physical object all
this from a Wikipedia okay or physical
body or simply an object or body okay is
a collection of matter
blah blah blah blah blah continues right
okay so it's a collection of matter so
we so what is a particle an object what
is an object a collection of matter
whatever that is okay
but the answers uh particle localized
object which can be described by several
physical or chemical properties such as
what volume density mass
and a very greatly in size and quantity
so we're talking about volume and size
so we are talking about a thing you know
at least that's what they're referring
to because they're talking about size
and volume you know take up space so
obviously they're talking about a ball
or a cube or some object that's what an
object is
okay so all the definitions point to an
object how does this become a Force how
does it become a verb any direction this
is where we have a little bit of
problems in the language and we have to
settle this language because these
people are contradicting themselves or
coming up with total irrationality
okay so what is a what is matter I mean
if
a particle is a bunch of matter or an
object is a bunch of matter what is
matter okay so one thing tells us occupy
space and has mass
okay so what is mass well he says uh
mass is quantity of matter
so we have a circular definition matter
is mass and masses matter great we
learned a lot
okay one is the quantity of matter and
the other one is a bunch of mass
so these are the scientific definitions
the mathematical physics definitions
that we have today masses matter matter
is mass great
how do we do it under the universal
movie
Universal movie again is I imagine
uh cross-section of time cross-section
of motion
we're talking about zero motion we're
talking about location a static concept
nothing moves
so God freezes the universe
everything is at a given distance from
everything else just a snapshot you just
took a snapshot he gave us this the
snapshot do you see anything moving in
that snapshot it's a 3D snapshot by the
way because everything's there in the
universe okay everything has a certain
distance with respect to everything else
meaning everything has separation with
everything else every atom in the
universe with respect to every other
unit uh atom all atoms are a given
location in that photograph with respect
to everything else
uh Universal movies is just a bunch of
photographs a bunch of locations of
every object uh as as they occupy
different locations
you know they move from one location to
another okay and then we call the series
of locations we call that motion but
here we're looking at a single frame in
the film
okay what do we see in a single frame of
the film well hopefully we don't see
anything that's moving in there because
it's a single frame and so where do we
put these uh words such as field and all
these good words like particle and
object and so on well we already were on
record saying that object is a static
concept you don't need to have anything
moving in order uh to define the word
object object just that which has shape
which is also static concept okay
particle if it's uh an object and
usually the word particle refers to an
object in rational science when
everybody says particle everybody thinks
of maybe a little speck of dust a little
ball a you know a small tiny Speck of
dust or ball or grain of sand that's
what a particle is that's what we
call a particle in science now the
mathematicians have distorted this word
because they say look a particle is is
not a particle it's not what you think a
particle is meaning it's not a corpuscle
and what do they mean well they mean
it's a you know one of those Quantum
things where well we don't really know
what it is because it's a vibration of a
field and you know all this other good
stuff no that's not the way it works in
science particle is a corpuscle just
like Newton thought about it okay and
everybody else before the 20th century
everybody thought of a particle as a
speck of dust and therefore it's an
object it's a static concept we do not
have to have anything moving in order to
understand what a particle is so you
can't say it's a vibration of a field
like they say today
where do we put the word Force well
Force obviously is a verb you know it's
a it's not a noun for the purposes of
physics it's a verb Force means pull or
push just like uh good old Weinstein
told us it's a push or a pull Force
means someone wins the tug of war okay
and so the question is can we reconcile
the word particle which is the carrier
of force what does that mean is a
particle of force a force a particle
obviously not particle is a an object
it's a ball think of it as a ball and
forces what a ball does okay so force is
not an object but they treat as an
object because they say oh it carries
the force it carries the interaction so
it's carrying a verb yeah and all that's
irrational we don't use that language in
science we don't use it in physics okay
so
um Force
very simple force is a verb it's pull or
push pull and push are both verbs
someone wins the tug of war we don't
care about the equation Force equals
mass times acceleration or uh
gravitational constant G Mass management
right distance squared we don't care
about any of that
that's a description we want to know
what the definition of the word force is
the word force is a verb for the
purposes of physics just like the word
motion it's not a noun it's a verb okay
the word orbit is a verb not a noun okay
all these words are verbs for the
purposes of physic so um Force pull or
push it can't be a particle can't be a
synonym of the word particle so to say
that particle is a force like you know
the gluon is the particle of uh of
attraction between quarks that's
irrational
either it's a particle or it's a force
and if it's a force you've got to
identify what's doing the forcing what's
doing the mediation what is carrying out
the activity that's what you got to
identify
and of course they can't do it with uh
in quantum mechanics because you know
they deal with something else they deal
with measurement and they deal with
equations and not with physical
interpretation meaning qualitative
um
explanations for how the subatomic World
works
with that I'll see you next week bye bye